my purpose in life was to spread
entrepreneurship and venture capital
around the world I just know that that
was why I was put on the earth I think
that most governments should abandon
their own currency because they are so
far behind Bitcoin so much better than
most of those currencies they should
just be adapting Bitcoin or maybe some
other crypto Fiats just not as good
now maybe Fiat will create maybe some
governments will create a currency that
can actually compete with Bitcoin but I
doubt it
they'd have to hire some really good
people and get them really working hard
on creating a great digital currency and
then they'd still be tribal because they
sort of say well no we're the government
and we have our tribe and our tribe does
whatever we tell them to do well now
that tribe can move the tribe can do
business anywhere in the world the tribe
can decide that maybe there's a better
way to go they only have one point four
million people in Estonia but they have
a hundred thousand virtual residents and
having that that's sort of the beginning
of governments competing for us and with
that data you can have something called
a smart contract you can build a deal a
contract into software all that data can
be combined now and can be extrapolated
and all the deep learning can happen and
that can make it so that the Diagnostics
that artificial intelligence provides
can be better than what a doctor
provides it's interesting well if you
you run the numbers you know Andrew
Carnegie had 1% of the wealth of the
entire world
one point so clearly the gap is
narrowing between the forest and the
richest at Draper University we've had
about 1,200 students they've come from
86 different countries they've gone off
to start 350 companies they've been
those companies have all been outside of
here when we start Draper University I
always get everybody standing around the
pool and and I say okay well what do you
do when you're gonna start a business
how what do you need to do and they say
well you got to build a product or you
got to find a customer you got today all
those things are very relevant but what
you really need to do is take the first
step and then I take the step and we all
go into the pool and they realize that
it is kind of a leap of faith yes and
you need that leap of faith if you're
gonna do something extraordinary with
your life boom what's up everyone
welcome to simulation
I'm your host Alan sake Owen we are
on-site at the beautiful hero city in
San Mateo California we are now going to
be speaking to Tim Draper hi Tim how are
ya Alan thanks for coming on for
downtown for terrific thank you my
pleasure I'm so pumped for this for
those that missed the first episode of
Tim you can find the link in the bio
below Tim let's just jump right into
things I'm so fast I saw the first one
they still want to come back for more
there's so much more to unpack Tim I've
been so fascinated with this question it
seems like one of the most first
principled questions that young people
should be endeavoring into when they get
birthed into this world what are your
thoughts on the purpose of this human
experience well it's really interesting
I think we're all sort of energy sources
on this planet flying through the
through the universes and and and we
seem very small in relation but I think
we we have a mission
and that is to you know explore new
world to think in terms of how to
improve the world that we live in how to
help each other kind of adjust to this
world and how in its changing
environment I think it's really also I
think we should all have fun this is a
is a wonderful experience we all get to
share in it's not always great but it's
wonderful and full of wonder and and if
it has a big impact on what we do can
have a big impact on future generations
both positive and negative and the
positive ones
think of all the incredible things that
great entrepreneurs have done and
they've overcome extraordinary barriers
to do so and most of the barriers are
cultural because culture doesn't like to
change very quickly but the
entrepreneurs are trying to take us to a
new place they're trying to change our
world you know there were so many awful
articles about Steve Jobs but think of
what he's done for all of us and same
things happening with with a lot of the
great entrepreneurs now where they're
getting sort of victimized they're big
attacked and I think that what they're
really doing is they're they're changing
culture and culture doesn't like moving
and and they're moving humanity to a new
level
and we're all going to be better off
because of them but a lot of humanity
fights them all the way to the end cool
so the purpose being that we want to
make this world that we've been birthed
in to better we want to explore new
worlds and entrepreneurs typically take
on this burden of genius to make the
world better and to move society in that
direction and I like that a lot Tim what
about your purpose so I my purpose in
life was to spread entrepreneurship and
venture capital around the world I just
know that that was why I was put on the
earth and now a lot of the world already
has it now so I feel like my purpose has
has is evolving and now I just want to
hyper accelerate it I want to educate
people get them thinking about becoming
entrepreneurs see how creative they can
become because we have we have new
platforms that will accelerate new
changes so if somebody comes up with a
new way of doing something the word will
spread around the planet faster than
ever before and so they can create huge
changes in our world faster and better
than they ever could before so this is
really it's a very exciting time for me
and I my guess is that it will get more
and more exciting as we're able to do
more things let's let's see this from
the perspective of you we're talking
about this big human experience that's
just so beautiful that we get to
experience it do you feel like it's
divine that we're given this opportunity
to endeavor into consciousness and
explore our passions and make the world
a better place do you feel like this is
a divine rock orbiting the star that we
all get to share I don't know really if
it's a divine Rock I do know that there
are all sorts of interesting spiritual
things happening around us I know I get
moved to do things and I know that they
are not always going to be popular but
but I get moved to do them anyway and
I'm sure a lot of entrepreneurs feel
that way that they are moved to make
some big impact and and actually
recently I've been sort of feeling like
I got to get this I got to get the world
to understand what the big sociological
change is is happening what what this
new change is going to be and I got an
early window on it because I got all
excited about Bitcoin very early well
its decentralized that means that it
pervaiz the world without having
friction on the borders it means that
the borders become less relevant the
borders were set up because we were all
tribal and and all of those tribes were
set up to protect the people inside the
tribe from the other tribe
well now any of us who do any kind of
international business or even business
across state lines understand that that
tribalism is certainly less relevant
than it ever was before
and so we so when when we see people
talking about trade wars or walls or
whatever we sort of say oh come on
you're going across purposes to the rest
of the of your population your
population is benefiting from all of the
trade all of the openness that is
happening between these countries and so
why are we doing this so I I look and I
say there's even more coming and that is
that a decentralized planet doesn't just
mean Bitcoin it doesn't just mean
decentralized currency
it could be decentralized services
government services can be provided
cross-border government services are
generally just a an insurance policy
they're set up like an insurance policy
they they provide us health care
insurance or workman's comp insurance or
pension insurance or whatever
well those now with Bitcoin and the
blockchain which is this perfect ledger
and smart contracts can be done
completely virtually they can be done
across
or you could you could have your your
social-security provided from Chile and
you can have your healthcare insurance
provided from Canada I'm a I'm the third
virtual resident of Estonia and that in
Estonia has already recognized that they
need to that they can provide services
across border they only have one point
four million people in Estonia but they
have a hundred thousand virtual
residents and having that that's sort of
the beginning of governments competing
for us they are accountable to us and we
can if we don't like what one government
is providing we could potentially go to
another and the best of governments or
the small governments the ones who can
move quickly are adapting very quickly
to this and they're starting to provide
better and better services to attract
more and more businesses and money and
citizens to their region or at least to
their virtual region and then the bigger
the bigger countries are having a back
wave on this they are they're having a
bad reaction and I look at some of these
things like the trade war the wall or
whatever the the tensions that are being
created by various state departments I
look at that as a reaction to the fact
that a lot of these government's have
services that are so antiquated they're
not needed anymore and they are trying
to justify their existence by creating
more tensions and we don't need those
tensions we're so much better off
without them and and I I liked it 10
years ago we were we were very we had a
very open border with China we both
benefit in a huge way from
open border now tightening that trying
to put a line between those two
countries both the leaders are hurting
their own populations so this this
beautiful endeavor into consciousness
that would have on this planet is now
becoming decentralized the amount of
friction in between financial service or
the friction between any type of
exchange of goods or ideas is just
becoming more and more frictionless and
that's helping us be more creative
execute more effectively this also ties
us into what you are saying a little bit
ago with your role your divine purpose
being in a sense you're kind of this
you're like riding this wave of like
fueling you're like kind of throwing
little fuels under people's
entrepreneurial booties so that they can
go and and continue endeavoring into
their success as optimally as they can
and so that's one thing that I feel like
more more venture capital now being more
easily accessed in Asia Latin America
Africa is now starting to empower
entrepreneurs to achieve what they set
out as their divine purpose so I like
that a lot now and I think you can start
a business from anywhere and that the
world anybody with a smartphone has
access to a search engine and that
search engine can provide them with
whatever information that they really
need and that brings everybody to sort
of the same level in order to start the
business that will take society to the
next level and so it is a great
flattening of the of the talent of the
earth everyone around the earth can now
see let's say you're you're into bio
computing well you could be you can
catch up with the rest of the world just
by kind of going online and figuring out
where
you should be in bio computing and then
and then you can figure out where
everybody is and then say well what's
the next step and start a business and
and get it funded and boy can you get
things funded easily now there there are
funding sources throughout the world
that all want more entrepreneurship in
their region and so people anywhere
around the world can can start something
this is really an exciting time for that
yeah and let's talk about how as as as a
in a sense we have more and more of the
wealth that's being created around the
world we have the first instances of
trillion dollar companies we have 100
billion dollar plus net worths for
people and the basic needs the standard
of living across the world is also
slowly increasing do you overall see
that hierarchy having a gap that's
closing or do you see a kind of
skyrocketing and the bottoms trying to
catch up but do you see it as being
exacerbated i it's interesting well if
you you run the numbers you know Andrew
Carnegie had one percent of the wealth
of the entire world at one point so
clearly the gap is narrowing between the
forest and the richest and the world's
middle class is growing at an
extraordinary rate so more and more
people are living in a at least a a good
a good level there are still places in
Africa and San Francisco where people
are living in squalor and and I think
that those kinds of things really need
to be changed and and it's interesting
by putting the band-aids on them we're
not helping by just saying hey we need
more services for the homeless all that
does is attract more people to that
place for to be home
what we really need to do is create
fewer regulations so that businesses can
thrive and then they can go build
low-cost housing so they can build a
better system for for delivering food
regulations are really hampering and
hurting in San Francisco has the worst
worst regulations I think of anywhere on
the planet and they have the most
homeless so whatever is whatever is
happening there is the wrong thing that
that should be happening and the freest
places tend to have the fewest homeless
some places like socialist Russia seemed
to have fewer homeless but they had they
in effect created an entire population
of homeless because people in Russia or
are in effect starving by comparison
because it's all top-down it's all
government controlled we do not want the
government controlling things our
government already has half of the they
have half of my money they have half of
the the economic value of the country I
don't think we're getting half the
services out of that half so I think we
really need to shrink our governments
and oh that's true all the way around
the world and the smaller governments
are thriving because they're attracting
all the businesses there they have the
wealthier populations because they're
attracting all the businesses so some of
these smaller countries Malta Gibraltar
Switzerland Singapore they're starting
to get very wealthy populations because
they are well sing for didn't used to be
free but it's a very free market economy
and and they're doing things to attract
businesses and they have very few
homeless in any
those places so so I think this this the
good news is that the rich poor
differential if you you can you can spin
the statistics anywhere the way you want
but generally the world is getting
wealthier and people are living better
yeah and at the same time that there's
this opportunity for those that have
accumulated quite a bit of wealth to be
able to procure whatever sort of
augmentations to their intelligence or
the metabolism that are now slowly
starting to evolve more and more I mean
just the simple way even in the past
that you could have kind of like someone
that was maybe a servant or a maid or an
assistant or whatever that would
basically do the routine mundane tasks
for you so that you could focus on your
creative best whereas people maybe in
the lower middle parts of the hierarchy
still also have to do the lower more
mundane or routine things as well so
there is this interesting item I
actually think that everybody everybody
has those mundane tasks and everybody
does them well Toby obviously it's been
true Bill Gates went on The Ellen
DeGeneres Show right he couldn't like
name any of the grocery store prices he
had hadn't been in a grocery store for
so long yeah so there are a few people
that are sort of missing that but think
of what he's provided to them oh well of
course I mean the guy has made of
extraordinary things if it happened or
the world end and there's a there's some
argument that says if he had kept his
money and Microsoft that we'd be better
off than him taking half his money and
giving it away there is a pretty good
argument for that if you if you continue
to build a business that has that kind
of impact on the world that that kind of
of a spread of wealth in the world that
that could actually be a bigger deal
than taking half of it and giving it
away yeah yeah and although you know in
giving it away he is
done an extraordinary job he could
absolutely smoke it's very much over the
numbers he's focused very much on you
know where are we having the most impact
where are we doing the best things for
Humanity and and so I really admire that
guy for that yeah like oh I hate it's
not power to him let you let other
people do the shopping for him in
thinking that other entrepreneurs are
making a fortune delivering him his
groceries you know I mean instacart and
sure were - yeah we're all delivering
him is a business and those
entrepreneurs are also making a fortune
that's right so we're providing those
services more and more and more easily
yeah the mechanisms at once wealth is
accumulated for propagating further
reshaping of potentially regulations to
propagate market advantage is something
that people are very hesitant of you
know you listed like making the
government very decreasing the size of
the government I am this is something
that is very much so in very interesting
topic to many people that could it
potentially be that having a way that
maybe people that accumulate lots of
wealth can then redistribute that amount
of wealth through entrepreneurship and
through creative endeavors rather than
just giving it away - there's so much
cool nuance there but one thing just
seems to remain certain and it's that
when you're when you're a young lion you
love capitalism because you're hungry
you're out in the world and when you
become an old lion and you've reaped
many of the roars of capitalism its
paramount to not try and go back and
reshape the regulations to propagate
your own advantage this is a very right
that is that has been our big problem
because the people who vote are older
and they are pushing for their agenda
and the people who we've elected I mean
look at the average age of the Senators
in the US
my god they are old they're older than I
am and and I'm not so sure they're
they're thinking in terms of you know
how well do we educate our population
how do we encourage free markets they're
thinking about things like you know how
cheaply they can get their pills and you
know what how they can live to be more
than 85 I'd say a point that's a pretty
interesting thing is that the average
age and the United States is one of the
most diverse countries in the world a
melting pot and our representation in
terms of diversity is quite low in the
Congress but other places in the world
are more homogeneous it was interesting
just recently coming back from China and
just seeing how there is no problem
there is no propaganda around diversity
in China it's kind of interesting we
have propaganda around diversity in the
United States you need to be diverse in
this way or that way yeah why force that
it's already happening I always think
you know I look around look around here
we we've had at Draper University we've
had about 1200 students they've come
from 86 different countries they've gone
off to start 350 companies they've been
those companies have all been outside of
here they go and they spread the good
word they create businesses wherever
they came from and they come from all
over I mean we have we have a great
relationship with Senegal with Saudi
with Taiwan with and and each of them
send some of their top people to come to
Draper University go start businesses
and they have an application process in
these countries that's quite rigorous
it's a very rigorous to get that get
that for you right we're and we're
looking for the best of the best and
what's great is that it comes in all
shapes and sizes and we
we love that I mean art we had a great
moment at Draper University there we had
12 people from Saudi in the spring and
and I was about to do the graduation
speech and I said hey a bunch of people
are missing and one of the Saudi women
said oh they're out praying and I said
yeah and I'm in here and I said come on
bring them all in here we'll all pray
and so then we all did the the Saudi
prayer and you know it was great fun
they we got everybody doing it going
down on their knees and up in it and
they chanted and whatever to Allah and
then I said anybody else have a prayer
they want to do and the Israeli woman
puts her hand up and said I'll do a
Jewish prayer she does a Jewish prayer
we all do the Jewish prayer and then
then three three Hindus get up and they
say well we'll do a Hindu prayer and
kind of a Hindu chant and we all did the
Hindu chant and then two catholics got
up and did some you know moment of
silence for and and I thought well you
know look we're we're all we've all got
the same deal here it's one big world
and and first I thought only at Draper
University and then I thought no this is
going to happen everywhere the
geographic borders are falling the
government's are are trying to sort of
isolate us and segment us and make us
feel like we're not diverse enough or
whatever that's nonsense we are all
going to be completely mixed up and
completely diverse and getting rid of
our tribalism and opening up and
becoming global is going to be step one
and and then it's just going to be one
big open world and I think governments
will be more like businesses they're
going to have to compete they're gonna
have to be accountable to their
constituents their customers and they
and it's it's high time they did because
government really has
had anybody you know challenging them
because they sort of say well no we're
the government and we have our tribe and
our tribe does whatever we tell them to
do well now that tribe can move the
tribe can do business anywhere in the
world the tribe can decide that maybe
there's a better way to go and in that
case they've got to start thinking well
wait how do I attract people from the
other tribes you know how do I grow my
my government against all these other
governments that are attracting my
people so I think this is the beginning
of something really extraordinary and
yeah you heard it first here at Draper
university the global decentralization
movement and it was so cool hearing
about how people are able to share their
different diverse prayers I love stories
and when you hear the press going off
about like you know oh we have to have
more of a certain type of people in this
certain thing all you're doing all the
press is doing is showing their own
prejudice they're showing that they have
a problem and they're trying to overcome
that problem but you know the rest of us
all know that I mean the people who work
for me are of all shapes and sizes the
people who come to Draper University all
shapes and sizes we've never even
thought about it but we just get the
best of the best and they come from
wherever they come from mm-hmm it's been
so cool actually making friends with
people from Saudi over the summer that's
been a lot of fun having that
opportunity while I've been coming
through that's opportunities that you
really have to seize because then your
your xenophobia or bigotries just
collapse immediately because you realize
that you both have very similar
principles around love and family and
compassion entrepreneurship making the
world a better place
okay let's break down this ideal
blockchain infrastructure for the
decentralized protocols around the world
because I think we now have Seoul
any of these you know you've been
listing now okay well governments we
want them smaller with less regulations
but also well although some people may
want bigger governments but what's great
is that we'll get a kick
yeah compel get to pay rec and so then
another you know another then question
would be okay well if we had this ideal
small government but this government
wants to have some sort of a
decentralized currency but then also we
have the private the private
decentralized currencies like Bitcoin
theorem then we also have these new
giants that are coming up around the
world the the Amazons and the Facebook's
and the the ten cents and the Baidu's
they're all trying to come up with their
own sort of of also decentralized
currencies so that's only one aspect of
it so I'm just curious that aspect but
then let's also talk about the like the
decentralized medical aspect people are
really interested in being able to have
a constant stream of my biometrics being
run up to the cloud and being constantly
processed and predicting pathology so I
can live longer things like that so
let's go first we'll go into the the
currencies of the world I think that
most governments should abandon their
own currency because they are so far
behind Bitcoin so much better than most
of those currencies they should just be
adapting Bitcoin or maybe some other
crypto it's it's much more efficient
governments with their own currency ten
and if the currency is not really
providing that good at service they tend
to be more corrupt and that leads to
more corruption there are there are
countries around the world whose
currencies drop 30% a year just against
the against a base of global currencies
and if that's the case give it up you
know you'll get rid of you'll get rid of
corruption you'll get rid of you'll
you'll attract all the entrepreneurs to
your country and your you'll just be
better off everyone in your country will
be better off except perhaps the person
who is corrupt at the top making those
decisions so I think that there is now a
competitive system for currencies you
have Bitcoin and then you have all the
Bitcoin knockoffs and then you have
currencies like Libra and then you have
the stable coins and you have a whole
variety of different currencies we now
can choose from and we're gonna be all
better off because those currencies will
be more frictionless keep better records
be transparent there'll be a
cross-border they they're open they they
can be used for things that the fiat
currencies can't be used for micro
payments for instance or or payment
across border without having to you know
give Western Union sixteen percent of
your money there there Fiats just not as
good now maybe Fiat will create maybe
some governments will create a currency
that can actually compete with Bitcoin
but I doubt it
they'd have to hire some really good
people and get them really working hard
on creating a great digital currency and
then they'd still be tribal I know that
Iceland I think created their own
currency I think was called the aurora
coin and they said okay you can wholly
spend it in Iceland it defeats the
entire purpose and so so sometimes
you're just going to have to you know I
mean
governments will have to let some things
go in order to compete for the next
century and so this is a really that's
pretty interesting it's it may be in an
interesting time now you talked about
healthcare I think health care is going
to change a lot too
and and let me break it down Bitcoin is
this currency that can be used anywhere
it's kept
everything's kept perfect track up on
the blockchain and and so that keeps
track of currency but it also keeps
track of data keeps perfect track of
data and with that data you can have
something called a smart contract you
can build a deal a contract into
software and that means that when an
event happens the payment happens or the
the event the event triggers money
moving from one place to another or data
moving from one place to another
well now you combine that with
artificial intelligence artificial
intelligence is really what very clever
computer experts have done is they've
put probabilistic assessment into data
and and they call that deep learning and
what they can do is they can they can go
out there and say hey what kind of
relationships do different things have
well the first of these was with
7-eleven they found out that beer and
diapers were always we're often sold
together something you never really
think but now you can come to your own
conclusions as to why beer and is always
bought when somebody buys diapers but
they decide they'd put the beer next to
the diapers after that and they sold a
lot more of both okay take that
technology to healthcare let's say
you've got all your medical records up
into the cloud and I've got all my
medical records up in that cloud so to
all the rest of the people in the world
and and it's not just our medical
records
it's our blood test results and our
genetic history and our Fitbit results
and what we ate for breakfast and what
airplane seat we were sitting in what
hotel we stayed at whoo
Mette what conference we visited where
we go and sit at work where the air
conditioner is all that data can be
combined now and can be extrapolated and
all the deep learning can happen and
that can make it so that the Diagnostics
that artificial intelligence provides
can be better than what a doctor
provides we have a company called cloud
medics and they actually provide they
they do this and they only with the only
with the doctor data they took the
doctor test which is like patient comes
into the office has a knee problem and a
headache what what do you do they the
average doctor gets about a seventy five
well they got an eighty five and when
combined with a doctor got a ninety one
on the test which means to me that you
kind of would rather have data doing
your diagnosis at least before the
doctor comes and does additional
analysis for you the last game we this
all ends up being though very securely
privately decentralized no silos this is
an ongoing conversation about how all
this data ends up being funneled up
there and you know the press brings it
all out it all everybody's out it
eventually and so holding on to your
data is going to only be a temporary
thing in the future I think anyway but
let's say people are really concerned
about privacy they can anonymize the
data that goes up there and then
anonymize it bringing it back to you so
you anonymize it that's who you are
it gets compared with all the other
anonymize data up there and then it
comes back to you in an anonymous way
and says here is your diagnosis so is
that a quantum encryption world really
picks up steam as we continue the course
of computing revolution the second one
that's happening right sure I think we
actually just I just look at quantum
computing is just the next level of
computing it's just going to be faster
better cheaper although all the great
things in it and and the things that
will allow people to do none of us can
imagine I think they're going to be
things that those quantum computers do
that none of us can guess what they are
but they're going to be great
crickets trying to imagine the big game
right so so that's part of healthcare
part of healthcare the Diagnostics part
of healthcare is going to change in a
big way
therapeutic s-- of healthcare is going
to change also because in therapeutics
data is now becoming really interesting
and relevant people can can do all these
experiments in wet labs where you which
used to take years and years and years
and now they can they can put a camera
over the top of it and determine what's
happening to each of those little vials
in a wet lab eating we run both
simulations that's okay that's even than
that it's just the first part and figure
yeah we have it well we have their
companies called Adam wise and Virgin
omics that can run put a disease up on
the screen and run all the drugs that
are off patent against it and then they
can find out that you know something for
Parkinson's might be good for the Ebola
Ebola virus or something for Alzheimer's
might be good for ALS and they'll just
run all these things against the disease
and then they'll see one that hooks and
then they go oh oh wow we can do that
and this is a drug that's already been
tested by the FDA I actually think that
those companies eventually are going to
do a better job of predicting safety and
efficacy than the FDA ever could and so
the FDA will use them as ways of
determining whether a
drug is going to be if a case
efficacious or safe yeah yeah do you
this is not eventually it might be that
that becomes the FDA it becomes our
initial intelligence FDA where they say
well no this drug isn't working because
we've run the simulation exact and it's
no good I mean eventually you've got to
put it into animals and humans this is
where these things gets out there
combined the quantum computing
technology the super intelligence the
simulations for the healthcare I'm
hopefully with a great deal of ethical
and moral and philosophical intent
behind the advances of Alibaba Tencent
the Chinese government Facebook Amazon
the US government Google Apple etc that
if you can plop these little ethicists
and philosophers into the engineering
teams that are building the super
intelligences that at least then there's
a period of reflection for the engineers
and the designers and ops people of like
okay well maybe there's a way to
actually work with the team Amazon 2d to
to decrease the silos of these data
points so that we can actually learn
more and predict more about your optimal
life outcomes so there's a bunch of
really interesting things that are at
play on on that on that big picture and
overall like the future of how that
information goes up on a distributed
ledger I think is fascinating and who
ends up being in ways of monetizing my
own data potentially and deciding when
to open up these valves to let data flow
do iona who owns it but just that whole
eat that whole technology stack is gonna
be really fascinating moving forward in
the future I think people are going to
own their own data and they'll provide
it anonymously maybe for free because
they want society to benefit from it but
but if they want it to go out to
somebody who's going to advertise to
them they
should they can probably figure out how
to be paid we've all seen those two
things though it's in right now it's and
we don't own any of our data and you're
saying we're all gonna own all of our
data and that gap is something that a
lot of people are wondering how is it
going to be closed you know it's it's
not going to be closed by regulation
it's gonna be closed by entrepreneurs
like data wallet coming up and saying
hey take back your own data join us
take back your own data and and join our
service and our service will allow you
to then take that data in and sell it
out to wherever you want to sell it out
to I end to feel like giving out the
data is
a real benefit to me because I end up
yeah I don't drink and so I sit there
and I watch football games and I'm
sitting here watching three quarters of
more beer hats and I'm thinking you know
yeah you guys could do a lot better than
and in so that can be very targeted and
I would much rather see something that's
relevant to me the beer ads not relevant
to me yeah yeah let's talk let's talk on
the future of just in general humans and
what we're going to be doing if we're
talking about super intelligences we're
talking about quantum computing we're
talking about these designer virtual
worlds that people can immerse
themselves in and design them and play
in them what is the role of the human
when super intelligence can just run all
of the creative computations much faster
than we can and just create things with
nanotechnologies just what is the future
of what we do yeah it's fun my son said
said AI is gonna take all of our jobs so
what do we do then and what's great
about it is it's like you know if
everybody was a farmer which they were
way back when and the hoe came out or
the tractor all of a sudden you know now
it's like three
percent of the world as a farmer the
other ones all had to figure out what
else to do well we're very creatively
humans and we will come up with all
sorts of new things to do and I can't
imagine how exciting it will be when
when let's say only 3% of us are doing
the things that are that we're doing
today and the other 97% are doing
entrepreneurial things that could have a
big impact on the rest of us so I am
very excited by that I mean if you can
get a machine to do something for you
during the day do it because then you
can have you can go out and you can
create more you can do more you can have
more leisure time you can have more more
time for thought you can figure out new
ways for those machines to help us so I
believe that humanity moves up there are
these there are temporary tragedies and
those are people who hey I spent my
whole life being a buggy whip
manufacturer I'm the best buggy whip
manufacturer in the world then they come
up with this automobile you know what do
I do
I've got to reinvent myself and I'm 55
or whatever that kind of thing that will
be there will be those tragedies because
AI when when people use AI to do venture
capital I'm gonna have to go figure out
something else to do but I'm kind of
excited about that opportunity you know
so that so that the mundane part of
enter capital is done by AI and then I
can filter it down and I focus just on
the ones that matter you know the
self-driving car uber has been fantastic
for this gig economy and getting people
off the street making sure everybody's
working and that is really exciting it's
been fantastic well all those people if
there are self-driving cars are gonna
have to find something else for the gig
economy but
and they see the regulations are trying
to kill the gig economy which is just
ridiculous they're trying to make it so
that everybody has to be an employee of
uber you go out and you drive once a
week or twice a week somehow you're now
uber is now responsible to you forever I
mean it just makes completely no sense
and I think that's driven by very
powerful public employee unions who are
saying you must be you must all be the
same I believe people are the beauty of
the world is that people are different
and they come up with different things I
don't think the beauty of the world is
that we all are automatons and are all
doing exactly what the public employee
unions are telling us to say of course
the next time by the way I like private
unions I think that that battle should
always rage on between the private
employee and the management but public
employee unions wait why is our
government unionized and growing I mean
it's like they've they've just decided
that they're all going to live better
lives than the rest of us it's it's
getting to be more of a you know the old
dictatorships and strong socialist
governments we don't need that and we
are way better off if we go out and we
create our own world make it great and
and have let the thousand flowers grow
yeah everyone's own unique creative
potential being maximized next time we
talk we'll get the full did I fall so
into your passion about trying to
restructure even break apart like this
full state of California and figure out
how to separate it up and figure out how
to optimally run a governance I'll ask
you some more quality consistent it's
consistent with me because I'm saying
governments have to now compete they
have to be accountable to their people
this is what you can so I'm saying yes
saying hey California has this weird
monopoly because they have the whole
coastline
that that's relevant I mean Oregon and
Washington have a coastline but people
aren't hanging out at the beach there so
they have this beautiful part of a state
that they control and and they really
need something to break that up and make
it make it more competitive and we'll
talk about maybe some of those dynamics
and also some of your other governance
principles maybe as we do more rounds
together on the show too many people are
wondering what would be maybe one of the
most profound things that you've learned
in your adventure of consciousness
here's what I've learned taking that
step trying is the most exciting part of
life and I think everyone benefits from
the idea of trying stuff and so whenever
you're in a quandary whether you think
this is a safe thing to do or a or
something that other people will think
is a bad idea
do it anyway I think we're we're so tied
up in safety that we that were like
Bubble Boy were over over protecting
ourselves in and I think we need to take
more chances and try new things and and
that's the beauty of life that life is
so much more fun when you try something
new the world opens up to you you try it
you go oh that didn't work we'll have to
try something else so I I believe that
that that's one of the keys to life to a
happy life is to keep trying new things
keep trying to do something that and
also to have some sort of a mission in
your life even if it's gonna change go
have a mission it's it's a it's it's fun
because then you you know that you
you will take those chances toward a
purpose and if you have that purpose
they it it it in effect justifies it to
yourself that you can go ahead and try
these things so take that I would say
take those I wait you know and we when
we start Draper University I always get
everybody standing around the pool and
and I say okay well what do you do when
you're gonna start a business how what
do you need to do and they say well you
got to build a product or you got to
find a customer you got a today all
those things are very relevant but what
you really need to do is take the first
step and then I take the step and we all
go into the pool and they realize that
it is kind of a leap of faith yes and
you need that leap of faith if you're
gonna do something extraordinary with
your life I love it okay thank you my
pleasure thank you good yeah it's such a
good ending such a good piece of wisdom
for us at the very end take that leap of
faith everyone into your mission into
building the future everyone thank you
so much for tuning and we greatly
appreciate it do check out all the cool
links in the bio below to Tim's work
check it out and support them join them
in the endeavors have more conversations
with your friends families co-workers
people online about all these topics
that we talked about today on the
episode and also support us help us
continue doing cool things like coming
outside to Hero City for these
interviews you can find all of our links
in the bio below and go and build the
future every manifest your dreams into
the world we love you very much thanks
for tuning in and we'll see you soon
peace
[Music]